okay welcome back everybody okay this is
the last time I'm going to see you all
for about a week okay there will today's
Monday yes good Wednesday and Friday I
won't be here next Monday as a
university holiday okay it's like
Presidents Day or Washington's birthday
something like that and so there's no
class and I will see you next Wednesday
a week from two days from now nine days
from now okay so this is a little bit of
an inconvenient time to have a break
because we're just building steam to do
partial differential equations but the
next three lectures that I want you to
watch are actually already online
I'll just I've already pre-recorded
these two summers ago in fact these were
the first video lectures that I ever
recorded so you can go to the course
website click on the video lectures
online you'll see my face with my kid on
my shoulders and you click on the video
feed apparently this is on air right now
and so the lectures for February 11th
13th and 16th are online ok 11 there's a
bonus lesson 13th and 16th are the bonus
lesson is like 4 or 5 minutes long so
that's not it's just a little mini
MATLAB thing ok so by the time I get
back 9 days from now I would like all of
you to have watched these three video
lectures and the entire point of these
video lectures is that they're they're
about the fast Fourier transform in the
computer ok so we've been deriving the
Fourier transform in the Fourier series
by hand you know on the whiteboard the
three video lectures that you're going
to watch next week are all about how to
do Fourier transforms in a computer ok
so
would I take some actual data and
compute its Fourier transform how would
I Fourier transform an image for
compression so all of you know about mp3
and JPEG image formats and audio formats
these are entirely based on Fourier
transform compression okay so if I take
images or audio signals and I Fourier
transform them it turns out that most of
the signal is zero or nearly zero and
you can throw it away
okay so so that's what you're gonna
learn about next week and when I get
back on Wednesday we're going to start
up again dealing with partial
differential equations okay so now we
have a lot of tools we know about
separation of variables we know how to
derive partial differential equations
from physics conservation laws and now
we're armed with the Fourier series in
the Fourier transform okay so we're
gonna start solving more PDEs next
Wednesday and in particular we're going
to start with a simple system like
guitar string where you have waves as
solutions okay and whenever you see sine
waves now you should be thinking Fourier
series or Fourier transform okay and
we're going to solve this not only
analytically right we're gonna take you
TT equals some constant u xx maybe this
constant should be called C the wave
speed and if you Fourier transform this
equation you get an ordinary
differential equation the second
derivative in time equals some constant
u X X and this u xx turns into a
polynomial in the Laplace the Fourier
variable so anyway we're gonna solve
this by hand next Wednesday we're also
going to start solving it on a computer
with a fast Fourier transform and once
we learn how to solve these simple
linear systems where we actually know
the solution then we're gonna start
solving nasty nonlinear partial
differential equations like the
Schrodinger operator okay so we're gonna
solve like fluids equations and optics
equations that you can't actually solve
by hand using the fast Fourier transform
in the computer okay so are there any
questions about where we're going or
where we've been or anything from the
last lecture on the Fourier transform
nothing okay I realize it was maybe a
little bit unfair to give you a pretty
difficult lecture on the day that the
midterm was due so I'm just gonna
rewrite and just very very briefly
summarize what we derived so we have the
Fourier transform pair so the Fourier
transform of some function f is equal to
the integral from minus infinity to
infinity of my function f this is
probably a function of some spatial
variable X or of time T and I take that
function I multiply it by e to the I
Omega X and I integrate with respect to
X from negative infinity to infinity
okay so f is my function in the real
space in space and f hat is my function
in the frequency domain so this is a
function in space or time usually I mean
space because I'm integrating from minus
infinity to infinity and I don't always
like to think about time as going from
minus infinity to infinity and this is
my Fourier transform and this is in
frequency domain or another way to say
this is that this Fourier transform
function f hat is a function of a
frequent frequencies Omega okay and if I
have this Fourier transform I should be
able to define an inverse Fourier
transform if I take my function and I
bring it to the frequency domain I
should be able to bring it back to the
spatial domain through an inverse
Fourier transform and that's going to be
given by my function f I can recover my
function f by taking a similar integral
in the frequency domain of F
hat Omega with respect to e to the minus
I Omega X and what am I going to
integrate this with respect to I have a
function of frequency Omega and I want
to recover a function of X so what do I
integrate this function with respect to
D Omega ok so you can see that there's
this kind of dual structure here to get
my frequency domain function I integrate
my real spatial function times e to the
positive I Omega xdx to go back to the
real valued spatial function from my
frequency domain I multiply it by e to
the minus I Omega X I integrate with
respect to Omega so I'm integrating out
all of my omegas here and this is a
definite integral so all of these omegas
really go away ok so this is the Fourier
transform pair
okay why do I want to write my Fourier
transform pair like this why we're a
Fourier series not sufficient in the
first place seems like we could do a
whole lot with Fourier series yeah
because they're forced to repeat my
Fourier series is only to find so my
Fourier series is defined on some
interval let's say 0 to 2pi or minus LDL
or something like that let's say minus L
to L and so I have some function that
does you know anything I like but then
the assumption of the Fourier series is
that this is going to keep repeating I
can't actually make it repeat that this
would the assumption is that this is
repeating on other 2l intervals plus or
minus 2 LS and so we want to be able to
define Fourier series on the entire
spatial domain right I might want to
have some solution that isn't bounded
from minus L to L but is actually an
infinite representation of an infinite
spatial domain function ok and how do I
interpret this integral so I have my
function f of X and then I have these
I'm multiplying this by e to the I Omega
X and I'm integrating over all X so how
do I interpret this e to the I Omega X
term
Oh mango how much of everything you have
yeah for Ichiro Mecca I'm having up how
much of that frequency expresses EFT in
that entire domain - infinity to
infinity so this really is a change of
coordinates I'm changing coordinates
from X spatial variable into Omega
frequency variable and you know this is
a little confusing to me and probably a
little confusing to you guys also when I
said that the Fourier series and the
Fourier transform is a coordinate
transformation from our function f of X
into sines and cosines basis or into
this e to the I Omega X basis and the
reason this was confusing to me I
realized just now is that I didn't
explain where we were transforming from
so we're transforming F into sines and
cosines but where were we before okay so
what is the basis that I'm using to
express f of X it's not even just
Cartesian X&Y exactly like that's two
dimensional or three dimensional it's
something a little different it's weird
so what I'm really using for f of X
let's say that this is X and this is f
of X is I'm really adding up functions
I'm really adding up these little Delta
functions
so the way that I'm writing this f of X
is I'm writing it as some value F at X 1
X 2 X 3 X 4 and so on I'm really writing
this in terms of the function value at
all of these discrete locations in X so
this is kind of a discrete spatial
representation of my function whereas
here in this representation I'm writing
f as a sum of a bunch of sines and
cosines ok so both of them are a little
bit weird but it is a coordinate
transformation from the normal
definition of a function as being
evaluated like at all of the locations X
to a new coordinate system where we're
looking at how much of f is in each of
these frequency components on that go ok
so let's drill a little bit deeper into
what we mean by this f hat so what are
the properties of F hat of Omega so
first of all this is a complex valued
function and this is complex valued even
for real valued f of X ok and so the way
I think about this is at each Omega at
each frequency let's say 2 Hertz
f of 2 Hertz or 2 times 2 pi is going to
be a complex number it's going to have a
magnitude and a phase ok so I have the
magnitude of F hat Omega is the
magnitude and what I'm calling the angle
of F hat Omega is equal to the phase and
this these are just this is just the
notation is you know an angle or
absolute value because any complex
number remember we can write as some R
of Omega e to the I theta of Omega right
so my Fourier transform f hat can be
written as some radial radius function
of Omega times e to the I you know theta
function of Omega and it for every
frequency Omega there's a real there's
an R and a theta and this theta tells me
how much of this magnitude is in cosine
vs. sine phase okay because remember
this is R times cos theta plus I sine
theta okay so for example if my f hat at
2 Hertz if f hat at 2 equals 3 I then
what I know from this is that my
function has amplitudes 3 and it's
purely in this sine direction ok if it
was if the if my Fourier transform f hat
was just 3 then my my spatial function
would have three signs at this frequency
but they would be in the cosine phase
okay so if the if the if the Fourier
transform is a real number then we're
dealing with cosines
if the Fourier transform is an imaginary
number we're dealing with sines and this
can be some real plus imaginary number
it can be 3 times 1 plus I and this has
some sign and some cosine phase in the
function or some phase between sine and
cosine is a better way to say that ok so
are there any questions about the actual
definition of this Fourier transform
okay there's a couple of things I want
to do one is I want to actually do an
example of how to compute the Fourier
transform of a real function and the
other thing I want to do is I want to
show you some of the important
properties of Fourier transforms like
how they operate on functions unlike the
derivative of this function or on
convolutions of functions so which would
you like to see first would you like to
see a concrete example of the Fourier
transform or more properties of the
Fourier transform sorry example good I
was hoping you'd say that okay so the
example there's a ton of examples you
can do this for basically any function
that's well behaved and I would
encourage you to actually do this for
lots of functions that are well-behaved
so as an example we're going to compute
the Fourier transform which I denote by
this script F okay that's my Fourier
transform we're going to compute the
Fourier transform of our function of X
and I'm going to tell you what this
function of X is so where f of X equals
first I'm going to draw it
okay just a hat or a triangle okay but
not a repeating triangle this is really
zero forever before and after so this is
different than the Fourier series okay
because the if I computed the Fourier
series of this shape then there would be
this assumption that there are repeating
triangles forever okay so this is the
shape this is a triangle with width L
and height a and so I can say that my
function f of X is equal to well it's
zero for X less than zero it's equal to
2ei x over L for X in 0 to L over two
between here and here it's just a line
with slope 2a over L on the second
segment it's a line with slope minus 2a
over L so 2a over L times L minus X and
it's equal to 0 for all X greater than L
so this is a relatively simple function
but what we're going to do is see how
much how many sines and cosines do I
need to represent this function what are
the proportions of sines and cosines
that go into this particular function
which is a triangle from 0 to L and it's
0 - you know everywhere else ok any
questions about the set up on this
problem does this make sense that we're
gonna take the Fourier transform of this
function you could also take the Fourier
transform of x squared
maybe not x squared because it blows up
maybe something like 1 over x squared
you could probably Fourier transform
that okay so our Fourier transform
function is f hat of Omega equals the
integral from minus infinity to infinity
of our function e to the I Omega X DX
okay now fortunately our function is
zero
most places right so this integral
becomes a lot simpler and I can say this
really equals the integral from zero to
L over two of this function times e to
the I Omega X plus the integral from L
over 2 to L of this function times e to
the I Omega X ok the X plus integral L
over 2 to L of the other function to a
over L L minus X e to the I Omega X and
D X ok and now we get to just break
these up and integrate like crazy so how
do I want to do this the first thing I'm
going to do is pull out so there's a lot
of algebra involved in doing this
integral these integrals are usually a
little bit nasty but I want to go
through it just to show you that it
really isn't that complicated it's all
simple calculus so we're going to pop
out the 2 ei over L outside of both of
these and I'm also going to break this
down into two separate integrals L times
this minus x times this ok so we have 2a
over L times this first integral
integral 0 to L over 2x e to the I Omega
xdx plus this L e to the I Omega X term
plus integral L over 2 to L of that plus
L over 2 to L of X is really -
okay good if there if I do anything
wrong or if this becomes confusing at
any point please stop me now it looks
like we might actually get some
cancellations because these are pretty
similar terms so does anyone remember
how to integrate so this one's easy
right e to the I Omega xdx what's that
integral 1 over I Omega e to the I Omega
X right evaluated at plus or minus
infinity so this one's easy
but how do i integrate X e to the I
Omega X DX well what's the method I
would use I would use a like integration
by parts yeah so integration by parts
which is basically the integration
version of the chain rule and I would
get something like 1 plus I Omega X e to
the minus I Omega X something like that
ok so I'm just going to write out all
the terms it's gonna be nasty ok so this
equals to ei over L times this term I
get something like 1 plus I Omega X over
Omega squared e to the I Omega X and
we're evaluating from 0 to L over 2 plus
this thing integrates this is a little
bit simpler I'm actually going to switch
the order I'm going to do this one the
first one the third one and then the
second one because the first and the
third are kind of the same integrand so
the third part is 1 plus I Omega x over
Omega squared same exact thing e to the
I Omega X this is a minus sign out front
because this has a minus sign and here
I'm integrating from L over 2 to L and
now this middle term is pretty easy to
integrate that's plus
el e to the
in my notes I have a minus sign on every
single integral on all of these
exponents I'll just act like that's not
there okay so this is the function we're
dealing with in my notes every single
one of these has a minus sign which I
don't think is supposed to be there okay
because in my notes there all have
negative signs okay in there might be a
sign errors in the denominators but it's
kind of irrelevant I'm gonna keep going
incidentally I just found out so you've
probably heard of the Raspberry Pi
computer it's like a little cheap $35
computer and I got one over the weekend
and it turns out that it has Mathematica
built into it for free which is totally
worth $35 and if I had used Mathematica
I could have checked these integrals and
they wouldn't have minus signs but they
do I'm just gonna keep going if there's
a minus sign it's not a huge deal okay
you can kind of work through it and see
if it's a big deal or not but I'm pretty
sure it's not okay so if I expand out
all of these all of these top and bottom
limits then I get six terms and a lot of
them cancel out and I'm just gonna skip
the step where I write down all six
terms because it's not going to help
anyway so this once I cancel out all of
my terms I get something like two to the
two each of the
I Omega L over two minus one minus e to
the I Omega L right because I've
evaluated this at L over two and it out
okay and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to multiply this by e to the minus
I Omega L over two so this term is going
to go away this is just going to become
a 2 this is going to become minus e to
the I II to the minus I L Omega over 2
minus e to the positive I Omega L over 2
so minus and plus and since I multiplied
this whole thing by e to the minus 1/2 L
Omega I I have to multiply it on the
right side by e to the plus I Omega L
over 2
okay good I convinced myself this minus
sign doesn't actually matter sorry these
are really are all positive eyes there's
probably a minus sign somewhere in here
but it really isn't a huge deal
okay now what do i what am i able to do
when i see e to the minus something plus
e to the plus something right it's
either like a a sine or a cosine type
thing so this one in particular is I'm
just going to divide everything by two
here and multiply by two here so this is
four times one minus this divided by two
minus this divided by two and this thing
looks a lot like cosine of Omega L over
two so this is one minus cos Omega L
over two okay the last thing I need to
do is one minus cos of something over
two is sine squared of Omega L over four
and I have 8a over Omega squared L times
e to the I Omega L over two okay so this
is kind of a nasty process to go all the
way through here I'm relying a lot on
trig identities and a bunch of nonsense
but the basic idea is I can do these
integrals I can go through a bunch of
steps and I get some function of Omega
this is f hat so we've done it we've
computed the Fourier transform of that
triangle hat okay and there's almost
certainly a minus sign that got screwed
up somewhere but this is squared and
this is e to the I something so I don't
care about the signs and notice this e
to the I Omega L over 2
in my notes has a minus sign but each of
the I anything is gonna be sines and
cosines and it's gonna have magnitude 1
so this is not unstable or stable it's
just sines and cosines okay so what I
want to do now the point of computing
these Fourier transforms is not just
some esoteric exercise and integrals
what I really want to do is show you how
to actually plot and interpret before
you transform once you get it because
these integrals most of us don't
actually ever have to do these integrals
again because we have computers and so
once you get the Fourier transform
interpreting it is what we really should
be learning how to do okay so we're
going to take this function and we're
gonna plot its magnitude and phase okay
so what is the magnitude of this complex
valued function
Plus this term right because the
magnitude of e to the I whatever is one
so all the magnitude is in this real
valued part and all of the phases in
this part okay so the magnitude of F F
magnitude is equal to 8 a over Omega
squared L times sine squared of Omega L
over 4 and the phase of F is just equal
to this exponent which is Omega L over 2
super simple in my notes this is a minus
Omega L over 2 R again shouldn't really
matter that much okay so if I plot this
in Omega I can plot the magnitude of f
hat and I can also plot the phase of f
and that hat so for the magnitude this
is pretty simple we have this is a
function of Omega right so what I really
have is some constant divided by Omega
squared times sine square root of Omega
at a constant frequency and so what this
looks like is
this kind of decaying sine wave sine
squared wave the height of this thing is
a L over two the frequency is four PI
over L 8 PI over L 12 PI over L so this
thing will go to 0 at exactly multiples
of 4 PI over L and the envelope of the
decay is 1 over Omega squared so what
this is telling me is that my frequency
content is actually rolling off as 1
over Omega squared so although my
triangle wave function does have some
content of infinitely high frequency
it's very very very small in magnitude
okay and then I can also read the phase
this one's even simpler this is just a
linear function of Omega with slope L
over 2 slope L over Q okay and this
essentially tells me if I want to know
how much of any frequency is in this
shape the way I would do that is I take
the Fourier transform and I go look up
that frequency let's say I want to look
up the frequency 2 PI over L well so I
go to 2 PI over L and I say ok well it
has this much magnitude of that sine
wave and exactly at this phase and so if
I wanted to take that I would say so
this would be 2 PI over L so that's a
sine wave of frequency 2 PI over L and
it has a magnitude of let's say that
this number here is 4 whatever then this
thing would have a magnitude of 4 and a
phase of whatever this theta is so to
have a phase
of whatever that data is so I can really
take this function and I can break it up
into real honest-to-goodness sine waves
and if I added up all of those sine
waves I would get this function okay and
this is how you interpret the magnitude
in the phase of the Fourier transform it
tells you literally what is the
magnitude of that sine wave at that
frequency and what is its phase what how
much shifted is it left or right okay
questions about this example of a
Fourier transform yeah if you took the
inverse Fourier transform of this
function you would get exactly that
happen all right
piecewise it wouldn't be a nice function
you'd have to evaluate it numerically
like taking the inverse Fourier
transform of this would be a huge beast
and if you wanted to do that you would
have to evaluate this numerically but
you could show that the integral would
be 0 up to some L and then it would you
know start looking like this it actually
might not be that complicated you should
try it I mean I'm imagining if I
multiply this thing by e to the minus
Omega X and I integrate from minus
infinity to infinity I mean think about
what function you have to integrate to
get this like the derivative of this
looks like zero positive number negative
number zero right this is the derivative
of my function D F DX so I'm imagining
that my integrand in my inverse Fourier
transform might be kind of simple I
don't know this is purely a guess it
might be a real beast I don't I don't
know but I think that this is something
you can definitely try either
numerically or by hand that's a good
question so computing the inverse for eh
form like usually if one of them is easy
the other ones gonna be difficult but
that's not always true okay other
questions about the Fourier transform
now in practice we're not really going
to be doing a lot of inverse Fourier
transforms or direct Fourier transforms
what we really want to do is we're using
the Fourier transform because when we
take our equations are partial
differential equations and we Fourier
transform them they become a lot simpler
to solve and then we can take those
solutions and inverse Fourier transform
and usually we do this with look-up
tables or Mathematica like we're not
usually computing a bunch of Fourier
integrals by hand because it's messy and
error-prone so what we really want to do
is think about how the Fourier transform
could make our lives easier in terms of
solving partial differential equations
okay so I'm going to tell you some
properties of Fourier transforms
now if I don't get through all of these
notes then just read through them
they're all pretty simple there's three
properties one is about taking the
Fourier transform of the derivative of
functions one is about convolutions of
functions and the other ones are about
like shifting your functions and things
like that so please read through it if I
don't get through all of this the first
property is the Fourier transform of
derivative of a function okay so let's
just go through this kind of step by
step we have the Fourier transform of DF
of D DX of some function f of X okay and
this is going to equal my Fourier
transform minus infinity to infinity of
f prime of X e to the I Omega X DX okay
and we're going to integrate this by
parts so let's just get another color in
here to make it a little easier so this
is my D V term and this is my U term
right integral of U DV equals UV minus
the integral of VDU okay so this equals
it equals UV evaluated at minus infinity
to infinity minus the integral of VDU
which is f of X now D this is minus
sorry
I Omega e to the I Omega X okay
so just in colors again this is U V and
this is the integral of the D you okay
now this function has to go to zero as X
goes to positive or negative infinity or
else this entire Fourier transforms not
defined so this term has to go to zero
so this goes to zero because f of X goes
to 0 for X going to plus or minus
infinity or else things are terrible and
remember e to the I Omega X this is just
sines and cosines this doesn't have
magnitude blowing up to infinity as X
goes to infinity so that's good that's
not not too difficult so we just have
this term and this term equals minus I
Omega integral minus infinity to
infinity of f of X e to the I Omega X DX
and this here is my Fourier transform of
F so this equals minus I Omega Fourier
transform of my regular function so this
is actually pretty simple
the Fourier transform of the derivative
of my function is just minus I Omega
times the Fourier transform of my
function it's super simple
ok now the reason that this is useful is
actually this is super duper important
this is probably the most important
property of the Fourier transform
because when we plug this into a partial
differential equation we get instead of
a differential equation we get an
algebraic type equation let's let's see
what this looks like so let's say that
we take our wave equation for this
guitar string and it's something like u
TT partial u with respect to time twice
equals some constant u xx and let's say
that I Fourier transform
I Fourier transform so I have this
function U of X auntie and I'm gonna for
you transform this into some function U
hat of Omega NT I'm gonna Fourier
transform with respect to X so my u TT
the partial derivative with respect to
time doesn't change anything but now I
have let's let's see what this looks
like what is the Fourier transform of
partial squared u partial x squared
right well I have you know this is minus
I Omega squared times u hat which is I
don't know minus minus is plus and I
squared is minus so minus I Omega sorry
so this is like minus Omega squared u
hat so my partial differential equation
now looks like u hat TT to partial
derivatives in time equals some constant
times u hat so what I did was I took my
partial differential equation this has a
partial derivative in both time and X
but now the partial derivative with
respect to X becomes a polynomial term
in Omega my new frequency variable and
so this is just an ordinary differential
equation there's no - there's only one
partial derivative it's a respect to
time there's no partial with respect to
space or Omega so this is actually just
like a teaser for what we're gonna do
when I get back on Wednesday is we're
going to use this property of the
Fourier transform and we're going to be
able to take our partial differential
equations that we would have to solve
with separation of variables and we're
going to write that partial differential
equation in the frequency domain and
when we write that partial differential
equation in the free
see domain it's going to be much simpler
to solve so maybe some of you are
confused why this is U hat tt why did
this term not change the reason that
didn't change is because let's say I
take partial squared u partial T squared
and I take the Fourier transform of that
I'm integrating with respect to X so I
can pull this whole partial squared
partial T out so that equals partial
squared partial T squared of just my
Fourier transform of U so that's equal
to u hat with two partial derivatives in
time u hat DT okay so the Fourier
transform of u TT is the second partial
derivative with respect to time of U hat
my Fourier transform of u so basically
this property and that Fourier transform
of derivative of a function property
allow me to take my partial differential
equation and turn it into an ordinary
differential equation this is an OD e
and this is my lambda okay this is just
an ordinary differential equation and
this is my lambda and I can tell which
of these frequencies is going to grow or
decay or what they're gonna do in time
but this is going to make our lives a
lot simpler the fact that we can take
the Fourier transform of the derivative
of a function and it gives us something
simple okay we have five minutes left
are there questions about this
derivative or the PDE or where we're
going
so this is gonna make a lot more sense
when we actually start solving this PDE
this is going to be something that we do
in class nine days from now it's also
going to be something that's on the
homework and I haven't figured out what
proportion is in class versus on the
homework but we're going to solve this
PDE by hand using separation of
variables we're also going to solve it
by Fourier transforming into this
frequency domain and solving this OTE
and then inverse Fourier transforming
the solution we're also going to solve
this numerically by taking this domain
and chopping it up into a bunch of
segments and using the fast Fourier
transform to solve this in that computer
so we're going to solve this three ways
separation of variables using the
Fourier transform and numerically and
we're going to see that you know this
really does make our lives a lot simpler
we can solve these systems much much
easier when we Fourier transform and get
rid of this spatial partial derivatives
okay so this is something that we'll be
building on the next three lectures are
just about Fourier transforms in the
computer and data science but I want you
to be thinking you know in the examples
that we talked about with the discrete
Fourier transform we can also take the
discrete Fourier transform of our
solutions to PDE s we can do it with any
function any vector you can represent in
a computer okay that's all for today I
will see you in nine days have a good
time between now and then thank you
you